So given my mom unexpectedly died on
Friday, given that backdrop, I've had a
good amount of time to reflect on a
concept that's been spoken about by many
but rarely defined, which is mental
toughness. And before I dive in, I want
to be clear.
I'm not saying that grieving is bad or
that there's a correct or incorrect way
to grieve or that you need to tough it
out independent of whatever it is that
you're going through.
And so please do whatever you want. This
is not my pulpit. But I wanted to share
my thoughts on the topic as it directly
applies to my current situation and
likely many of you here are dealing with
hardships of your own. So, what is
mental toughness? So I define it as the
chance a bad thing changes how you act
in a way that's against your goals. This
means mental toughness is not do you
have it or not, but instead how much do
you have? So, for example, if you have
lots of mental toughness, that would
mean a low likelihood of a negative
impact on your behavior. So strong mind,
weaker zero impact. On the other hand,
if you have low mental toughness, then
it'd be a high likelihood of a negative
impact on your behavior. So weak mind
equals strong bad impact. And so now
that we have that defined, we need to
create an environment in which mental
toughness can be exercised and ideally
measured. So let me show you a little
visual representation of how people act
when bad things happen to them. Bad
being against your preferences. And so
you can follow along with these little
numbers that I have here, but this is
the basic drawing of the context
of how this works.
So, number one, this is how you normally
act.
Then a bad thing happens. Sad face.
This is how much you act out.
The distance between these two points,
when you act out and then you recover,
is the is how long before you
restabilize your your behavior. How do
you How long does it take for you to get
back to normal? Then, after that point,
you have two alternatives.
Or technically you have an infinite, but
you can, in a good scenario, behave even
better and even more aligned with your
goals after that bad thing happens. You
can have no change in behavior, so you
were impervious to it. You got through,
got back on track. Or you can
permanently behave in a way that's
stabilized but worse. And so if we see
that as the
baseline model of behavior change, then
we can begin to apply our framework of
mental toughness to it. And so I'll
begin with an obvious observation. I
think that people mistakenly believe
that mental toughness is only one thing.
And looking at this model, I believe
that there are four separate components
that make up mental toughness. I also
believe that they exist independently
and only when taken in aggregate
can they give us a complete picture of
someone's actual mental toughness. And
so the four components are as follows.
Number one, tolerance. Number two is
fortitude and I'll define all these.
Number three is resilience.
And number four is adaptability. This is
what they look like
labeled
in our uh in our fancy model. So we have
our original little guy here.
So here to here
is tolerance.
Here to here
is fortitude.
is resilience and
here to here
is adaptability.
Okay.
So the first component
of mental toughness in my model is
tolerance. This is how much hardship,
the number of hardships or how long you
can endure hardship before you have a
change in behavior. This is before you
snap. This is how long your fuse is. How
much can you tolerate before you diverge
from your normal behavior? And so if
you're someone who has a long fuse,
aka it takes a lot to rock your boat,
you have high tolerance. Now, if you're
someone who has a short fuse,
anything can set you off
and you demonstrate low tolerance
compared to the first example. It
doesn't take much to get in your head,
to get you off your game.
That's the first component.
The second component of mental toughness
is fortitude. So this is number one,
this is number two.
So fortitude is the intensity of the
behavior change once your tolerance
threshold has been surpassed.
So think how low did you go or how upset
did you get?
I didn't mean to rhyme both of those.
That worked out well. So when something
bad happens, do you take a deep breath,
walk outside for 5 minutes and then come
back?
If so, you have high fortitude. Or do
you quit your job, get divorced and get
into hard drugs?
If so, you have low tolerance compared
to the high fortitude example. The third
is resilience. After a change in
behavior, so behavior's changed here,
right? After a change in behavior has
occurred from a bad thing, how long does
it take you to get back
to a new baseline, to to restabilize?
Do you bounce back in 5 minutes?
If so, you might have high resilience.
Or do you bounce back in 5 years? If so,
you have low resilience compared to the
5-minute person.
As an aside, here's something that I
think about a lot. In an instance where
you have something terrible to happen,
like death of a loved one, does the
amount of time it takes you to recover
have any bearing on how much you love
that person? Said differently, do you
need to suffer to prove your love?
And if not,
would any reasonable person want the
person they love um excuse me
And if not, would any reasonable person
want the people they love to suffer?
I actually didn't think it was going to
go this way. Anyway,
behavior. So just just something worth
considering.
So in other words,
maybe you suffer as long as you decide
is adequate. And if it's even partially
true, then it means that you have some
influence over how long you choose to
suffer. Tolerance is how long, fortitude
is how much, resilience is how long it
takes you to get back.
And then number four
is adaptability.
So,
how your new baseline compares to your
old baseline. This distance here.
In other words, are you better for this
the disruption? Are you permanently
worse
or you the same as you were before? This
would be the same. This would be
permanently better. This would be
permanently worse if we went underneath.
So, if you stabilize after bad thing
happens at a new higher baseline,
then you have high adaptability. You let
hard times beat the strength into you,
not out of you. If you stabilize to your
former baseline, just the same as you
were before after bad thing happens, you
have medium adaptability.
You demonstrated that you didn't allow
bad things to affect you.
And if you stabilize below, which should
be here,
then the hard thing beat the strength
out of you. Note,
if the new baseline changes in either
direction, positive or negative, then
the experience traumatized you. In other
words, you have a permanent change of
behavior from an aversive bad stimuli,
thing that happened. Now if that
behavior change is positive, then you
got better from this traumatic
experience.
If it's against your long-term goals,
then you got worse from it. But both
outcomes, however, mean that you were
traumatized. Like I said, you had a
permanent change of behavior from a bad
thing. AKA you learned something
different going forward. So this means
that trauma, as it relates to us as
individuals, rather than judging what
happened to us, can be a force for good
if we let it. So people who take my
words out of context want to make it
seem like I justify trauma when it
couldn't be further from the truth. I
hope that no one has bad things happen
to them. But I see bad things, things
happening against our preferences, as a
fact of life.
The only thing we have is our response
to those bad things, how we choose to
act or not according to the ideals that
we strive to live by. So I see these
four components as the things that
create mental toughness. And none of
these are binary, like you have it or
you don't. Instead, they exist on a
continuum.
It's how much or how little of each of
these skills do you have. And this makes
our behavior something malleable rather
than identity that we must be stuck for
for the rest of our lives.
And so now that we have a basic
understanding of these components, let's
look at some real life examples.
So if you had a 10 out of 10 mental
toughness person, so this is one
extreme. So you have somebody who's
maxed out all stats in all four.
Perfectly mental tough toughness. How
does this ideal person behave when
something bad happens?
They have huge tolerance, so almost
nothing bothers them.
They have endless fuse, right? And if
something does bother them,
the change is so small, it's almost
unnoticeable.
And as soon as it does happen,
they recover
almost immediately.
This gap shrinks. And not only that,
they use the experience
to get better.
So the end result is someone who just
keeps improving.
And so life happens
for them, not to them.
So what does it look like at the
opposite extreme?
So I'll show you what this looks like in
practice.
So for the first, the ideal mental
toughness person,
it looks like this.
So bad thing happens,
but they get stronger.
Bad thing happens,
they have this fuse, almost
imperceptible change in behavior, they
adapt. They get better. And that happens
over and over again.
Now,
in the opposite scenario, a zero out of
10, the absolute weakest mental person
you can imagine. You might know some of
these people.
Um
it takes very little to throw them off
their game.
So a tiny inconvenience can send them
spiraling.
That's low mental tolerance.
Then they dramatically change their
behavior, low fortitude.
Then they stay down for a long time, low
resiliency.
And not only that, when they finally
stabilize, it's at a new lower baseline,
low adaptability. And so you've met
these people, I've met these people.
This is the person who's broken up with,
gains 50 lb, loses their job, gets
addicted to drugs, and they never
recovers.
Life happens to them, not for them.
And of course, people in the real world
like you and I
usually sit somewhere in the middle of
these two extremes.
And so, as an example, you might have
someone who has a long fuse, but when
they snap, they really snap. This is
someone who has high mental tolerance,
but low fortitude. And if they stay
upset for weeks, low resiliency. But
maybe they come back to a baseline
again, so they have medium adaptability.
Give you a different example.
And these are probably some people that
you might know. Maybe it's you. So,
number two, maybe they have low
tolerance, high fortitude, high
resilience, and normal adaptability. So,
that would mean that many things bother
them,
but they barely change their behavior,
they get in a bad mood, cry, but then
they quickly recover to baseline. So,
it'd be like
low tolerance, they quickly get in a bad
mood and cry, and then boom, they're
back to baseline.
That's what that would look like. Or,
it's somebody who has low tolerance,
high fortitude, low resilience, and
medium adaptability, which is they get
in a funk easily, but then they stay
there for a long time, but it doesn't
ruin their lives. They just stay below
baseline for months until they finally
come back to normal.
And so I give these examples because we
all know people who fit these
descriptions, and maybe you match one of
them.
And I see being able to describe the
components of mental toughness is the
first step to improving them in yourself
and others. Just telling yourself or
others to toughen up doesn't actually
help anyone. But giving them clear
instructions they can use to change
their behavior over time can help them
improve it. And if you can improve it,
it no longer means mental toughness is a
trait you're born with, but a skill you
can develop.
So,
what to do about it?
Mostly notes to self.
[Applause]
If you want to develop mental toughness
according to this model, let me able to
flip it this way. You can rate yourself
on each of these four attributes on the
continuum.
And from there, if you realize your
largest discrepancy between actual and
ideal is just one of these four
components, then you have a specific
behavior that you can work on rather
than just hoping and praying you mature.
So, here's an example of each of the
behaviors that make up mental toughness
and how you can adjust them. So, let's
say that you're like, I'm a low
tolerance person. I got a really short
fuse. Okay. Then you need to practice
not giving power to something to ruin
your day. In other words, don't stop
being upset, just allow yourself to be
more upset about letting something
change your behavior than about the
thing itself. For example, I can't
believe that person said that thing to
me, and rather than lashing out, you
think, I don't want to give them that
level of control over my behavior. I
don't want to hand them the keys to my
mental car. Keep your hands on the
wheel. Be bigger than the pain.
Simply put, just continue to behave as
normal despite the fact that something
bad happened.
So, that's a low tolerance example. So,
how about a low fortitude example? So,
if you've ever heard somebody say like
bad things happen in threes, right? Or
uh you know, insult leads to injury, or
you let bad get to worse,
then you need to recognize as soon as
your behavior begins to change
here, as soon as it begins to change, to
not make even more bad decisions. You
can avoid the slippery slope, the
negative life snowball, by first
recognizing you diverted from your
normal behavior. Then, rather than
justify why it's okay, remind yourself
of all the even worse things that will
happen if you continue this course.
Continue down, right?
Or, just what happened to you the last
time you went down this road. The more
you practice this, the faster you catch
yourself from spinning out. And on a
personal note, I find this one hurts the
most for me because I have to admit that
I was too weak to control my behavior to
begin with. But at least now that I
recognize it, I can give myself the
opportunity to demonstrate strength
enough to change it. This action
reverses the momentum of the bad
decision, and begins the ascent back up
to baseline.
Third example. So, let's say you're a
low resilience person. It just takes you
a long like just takes you a while to
come back in. Like something pisses you
off or you know, gets you upset, it's
just like you just mull on it for a
while, you stew, right? And so if you
realize you've already messed up, no
matter how big or small, you just focus
on getting it back to normal independent
of whether you feel like it or not. So,
this doesn't invalidate your feelings,
it simply breaks the direct link between
how you feel and how you act. The goal
is to return to baseline as fast as
possible. Over time, you can act like
normal faster and faster until
eventually it's almost as if you were
never upset to begin with. AKA, your
behavior doesn't change at all. On a
personal note, this is the one that I
found to be the easiest to improve on
because as soon as you hit whatever your
rock bottom is
for whatever this upset thing is, just
reverse.
It's a it like it only controls you as
long as you let it. I'll give you a
final example.
So, if you realize, so adaptability.
So, if you realize that you're worse off
than you were before. You have some bad
breakup, you're like, I don't feel like
I have my mojo back, or whatever it is,
right? Then you can ask yourself, how
can I let this bad thing serve me?
So, no matter how bad it is, our moments
of greatest growth typically come after
our biggest upsets. So, if you were the
main character in a movie, and you know
it's a happy ending, and the character
gets passed up for the promotion,
doesn't get the girl, you know, the
person they cared about most died, what
would the character in the story do to
move the plot along to get the happy
ending? As soon as you recognize what
that character would do, or what what
world you would have to exist,
then do it.
Because guilt, AKA, you broke your own
rules, and shame, you broke other
people's rules, are only useful as long
as they get you to change your behavior
for the better. After that, they serve
no purpose. So, my hope is that by
writing this, I can return
above baseline
with a
um
deeper and better understanding of my
own relationship with things that go
against my preferences.
And maybe help one of you guys as well.
Uh beyond that,
for the uh I like to my my my my troll
note, uh for avoidance of doubt, I'm not
saying that you're supposed to numb
yourself or not feel your feelings.
I'm stating that you do not need to act
out your feelings. In other words, just
because you feel like doesn't mean
you need to act like treat other
people like or treat yourself like
And I think separating our feelings from
how we behave is a sign of maturity,
which has almost nothing to do with how
old you are, only how skilled you are.
And that means that you can work on it.
And if that's not a hopeful message, I
don't know what is.
So, thank you.
[Applause]